today though
we are delighted to welcome hanapulin
galai
who is a senior lecturer of judicial
holocaust studies in the department of
literature at tel aviv university
and the author of a book that
is right here uh ecology's
ecologists are witnessing language place
and holocaust testimony which came out
on yale university in
yale university press in 2018.
we have some information about the book
outside so grab a flyer on your way out
and hana is a remarkable polyglot
scholar with a
broad intellectual range um writing
articles
on everything from avraham switzerland's
poetry
to soviet songs and even contemporary
israeli politics
for instance for the nation in other
venues and she is
as a representative of an organization
called standing together
so she's a scholar who does not just
engage with her field
of study solely for the purpose of
scholarly production
but i think she clearly draws from her
work to inform her fight for
social justice causes today um
she'll be speaking about her book and
once she has
talked about 20 25 minutes and
afterwards her presentation will be
followed by a response from deborah
dwork
who was the founding director of the
strassler center for holocaust and
genocide studies and is the rose
professor of history at clark university
she's written numerous articles chapters
and many books i'm just going to name a
few
most recently 2011 on northwestern
university press was a boy in terezin
the private diary of pavel weiner
introductions and annotations she's
co-authored a number of books with
robert van pelt flight from the right
1933-1946 that came out in 2009
and auschwitz uh 12th 1270 to the
present
in the german edition of that book i
would note um
was voted the number one title in the
german national book critics list
uh in november 1998 and um
uh by newsweek it was voted as one of
the ten best books about poland during
world war
ii in august 2019 20 2009
uh there was an emmy award nominee
documentary based on this
work called auschwitz the blueprints of
genocide
produced by the bbc and it aired in
in the uk and in the us and it also
served as a central source for a
seven-part documentary series
also produced by the bbc called
auschwitz inside the nazi state
the books received national jewish book
awards and
many other awards but nonetheless we're
very happy to have
you here deborah and with that let's
welcome
hannah to the podium to give her
[Applause]
presentation
hi everyone thank you so much for coming
thank you stephen for that
generous introduction it's really quite
moving to
talk about this book here at the fortune
of
archive since i did part of my research
here and it was
generously assisted by joanne rudolph
who's here and
she stayed in touch with me for years
afterwards to really help me um
see whatever i wanted to see about the
archive and i think that as i
and i i did write this and then in
acknowledgments that that's
that's not a technicality helping
researchers
in the humanities in that way is a is a
statement it's a
statement of values to be both
someone who aggregates and organizes
testimony as well as someone who
facilitates
open research and new questions on it so
i really thank you for that
and thank you for having me here i want
to start
by i'm not going to talk about the
israeli side of the book because of the
time limit but if you want to ask me
about that later
i brought the book so i can look things
up
[Laughter]
so i want to start with that historic
date that stephen just mentioned may
2nd may 2nd 1979 and i do believe that
that's an historic date and that the
recording of holocaust testimony in the
last two decades of the 20th century
should be
considered a historical event in its own
right
an event of commemoration of archival
creation
a public declaration of values and also
critically an event of translation
scholars have rightly asserted that the
scale and technological practices of
recent holocaust
testimony projects have changed the
scope and circulation
of witness narrative but what remains
unaddressed is how these same testimony
taking projects
also attempted a radical act of
translation
a transference of knowledge and ideas
across
lingual and geographic borders
for example the usc shaw foundation
institute alone
has recorded testimony in 52 different
countries and in 36 different languages
bringing with it potentially specific
american rooted concepts of history
selfhood and suffering
my research investigates what happened
and what happens to the testimonial
enterprise
and the conceptual web on which it rests
when it arrives in different geographic
and
linguistic contexts or as i term them
ecologies of witnessing
viewed comparatively victim testimony
footage
reveals profound distinctions in how
people from different settings
tell the truth about the violence that
they endured in the holocaust
so i approached this question of
translation
through a specific case study
i look into holocaust testimonies
of video and audio holocaust testimonies
of lithuanian jews who were all born
before 1935 and they
survived the holocaust in one way or
another
so they have that much in common and
then after the holocaust
they either stayed in lithuania
moved to israel or moved to the u.s and
they chose to give their testimony
in this later period from 1979 on
in one of three languages in yiddish
english or in hebrew
so why did i choose lithuania for
this case study i hope that this map
will just give us
a reminder of how
lithuania was originally annexed the
soviet union in 1940
and then reincorporated into the ussr
after world war
ii so the reincorporation
meant that apart from those lithuanian
jews who happened to have pre-war polish
citizenship
holocaust survivors who returned to
lithuania after the war
were required to stay there at least
until the 1970s
so that meant that there was actually a
somewhat robust community of of
holocaust survivors
in lithuania after the war um
the community hovered around 30 000
members
and yiddish was actually quite prominent
in the
their communal interactions for
different reasons
so that ecology
interests me greatly and at the same
time of course
most of the lithuanian-jewish survivors
moved somehow managed to move to
either the u.s or north america or
israel after the war and they were very
instrumental in those places and leading
the way
in different commemoration efforts so
for those reasons i thought that
lithuanian jewry would make an
especially interesting case study
for roughly a decade i dwelt with over
100 testimonies of lithuanian jews from
these three settings
both as an interviewer and as a listener
over the course of that process i became
convinced that the witnesses language
place
environment deeply informs her mode of
truth-telling
the witness's ecological resources the
words
images and social norms at her disposal
shaped critical concepts like
justice guilt strength pain
and even love and family in the
holocaust
it is to this last point of difference
ideas about family and belonging and
holocaust narratives
on which i will focus my lecture today
a lot of the most prominent holocaust
narratives
in american culture are actually family
stories
the diary of anne frank one of the
reasons why
it's why it's considered appropriate for
seventh graders is that it tells a
family story
and the family story accompanies the
holocaust story
uh likewise art spiegelman's mouse
um narrates the holocaust through the
lens of an intimate father-son
relationship
and at the entrance to the united states
holocaust memorial museum
there is a small pre-exhibit of sorts
called daniel's story
which physicalizes that family focus
that we see
in in other literary texts and i think
that
um the family framework here the
the nuclear family as it's depicted
through a small household and the
intimate spaces of a bedroom a bathroom
a kitchen
is deemed appropriate as an entrance
space
an architectural choice because family
is thought to be a universal and
inviting
topic and much easier supposedly than
politics or or
or culture or resistance and
i would like to differ with that from
that position i think that
that family is not universal
and not in holocaust testimonies and
that the differences between
families stories across lingual and and
geographic boundaries
are quite significant to how they see
the holocaust as a whole and to how
witnesses see
the act of testimony so in this lecture
i'm going to examine just
one rich testimony from two of the
ecologies in question
an english speaker from north america
and a yiddish speaker from lithuania
this isn't quantitative sociology
so the examples that i the way that i
work with examples is not by finding
a median or a mean example and claiming
that they're representative
of everyone else like them but rather i
look for examples
from the group that i studied who pick
up
on important pressure points in rich
ways
okay so
the first testimony that i'll discuss
it's uh it's a fortune off testimony
from a woman named suzanne h
from the start of suzanne's testimony
her parents are not only themes of
narration they are the filter through
which she retrieves history
helping her to discern the relevance of
information and images that surface
from pre-war life for example suzanne
recalls the physical space of her
childhood
as a reflection of her parents
personalities
their home in the suburbs of vilna was
and i quote
a very pretty building with a garden in
front
every spring my father used to plant
flowers in front
i used to look forward to it taking us
on a tour
through her house and in a way through
her
parental child relationships she then
relates
i remember my mother having very
cheerful accessories
like her immediate physical surroundings
the larger political atmosphere
in vilna also appears in relation to her
parents
personalities suzanne tells that even
though they were highly secular jews
her father chose to send her to a jewish
school as a child
rather than a polish one because quote
he was angry at the way that the polish
people looked at the jews
so in this formulation anti-semitism
becomes a reality of past
experience something to which she is a
credible
eyewitness when it impacts her father
emotionally
bringing this social perspective into
the warriors suzanne recounts events of
the holocaust
through the prism of personal perception
and interaction with her parents and
brother
early after the german invasion of vilna
on june 24th 1941
suzanne recalled a conversation with her
mother during one of the early roundups
that year
i kept her i kept on telling mother oh
don't worry everything's going to be
okay even though i was petrified
this intimate dialogue is what makes the
event real
sparing in details about the scene
around her
suzanne is very precise about her and
her mother's emotional exchange
[Music]
suzanne and her family survived these
initial roundups
and were forced to move into the
villenaghetto at the beginning of
september
after a short while they were able to
move into the kylie's fur factory
on the outskirts of the city which was a
smart one of two small work
camps um just outside of vilma kais in
hakeepe
each of which was a small brick
enclosure with roughly a thousand jews
working and imprisoned there suzanne
explains that though her that since her
family did not have an official license
to be in kailis they were eventually
forced to move back
into the ghetto she briefly summarizes
the cultural milieu of the ghetto that
she found when she returned there
they had a theater they had some culture
they even opened a restaurant
and that's it events unfold
independently
from this cultural milieu the main stage
of causality is within the intimate
emotional space of her family we can
also
i can almost think of suzanne's
relationship
in her memory narrative to her cultural
milieu
um in the way that eric auerbach
describes
the uh protagonists in stendahl's work
he says
a man seems to be thrown by chance into
his milieu
into the milieu in which he lives
suzanne's focus on her
nuclear family relationship becomes even
more striking as the narrative
progresses the family sneaks
back into the kylie's work camp when the
vilna ghetto is about to be liquidated
there her parents are caught outside of
the camp and it's
it's a bit complicated i won't go into
it the guards agree to release her
father but not her mother
and suzanne envisions a conversation
between the two of them her mother
saying
you have to stay and find the children
you have to raise the children
he gave her all the jewelry he had that
was it
later i heard that they made them take
their clothes off at ponar and shot them
the loss of suzanne's mother the quick
depiction of her being stripped and shot
at punar
constitutes the turning point in her
view of history
the moment when life changed from
difficult to abnormal
evidence of this catastrophic rift comes
from within suzanne's body
she says i was 12 years old and i used
to wet my bed i later learned that you
want your mother back and this is what
we did
i was so embarrassed at the time in my
aunt used to tell
to yell at me and i didn't know what to
do
so she's focused on the pre-conscious
physiological reaction to loss
and in doing so she frames this moment
as a break
in the natural order of mind-body health
some people like one of my very own
dissertation advisors
david roskies have looked
at testimonies like this in the fortune
of archive
and criticized the interviewers
or the institutional culture for
supposedly distancing the survivor's
story
what from what they consider history
um and i disagree with that normative
position
it's not um it's not out of ignorance
or short-sightedness that witnesses like
suzanne
downplay a distinction a depiction of
the large room with you from which they
came
in dominique le capra's formulation the
story of a greater jewish collective
is absent rather than lost in
testimonies
like this in suzanne's framework and in
the book i do argue that there
are a great number of other survivors in
this ecology who
share this perspective in one way or
another the holocaust appears most
damaging when it unhinges the emotional
economy of
each household so if catastrophe occurs
in the psychic and sensational realm of
each family
then that is where history happens that
one had better examine the singular
family stories one at a time moving
household to household in order to
assess the damage of history
it is simply not especially relevant to
reconstruct social externalities of
jewish belonging
when internalities appear as such
powerful tools
for telling and explaining the truth
about the past
and in this sense also i distance myself
from some of the i guess you could call
them more
simplistic or aggressive critiques
of psychoanalysis that are out we
discussed some of them yesterday
at the uh the event for carolyn dean's
book
where um in denaturalizing
uh personal experience as a mode of
remembering history and i do think it's
it's worth denaturalizing and not
considering it universal
people then delegitimize it and
that's just as as culturally intrusive
and dismissive
as doing the opposite which is um
universalizing and claiming that
everyone should testify that way
so so far i imagine that
this is relatively intuitive for you
i will just point out before i move on
to the next session that there are
witnesses who comment on and even
dispute the kind of psychotherapeutic
nuclear family focus that i pointed out
in suzanne's story
as just one example a show a foundation
witness named meir shapiro
argues with his interviewers questions
about his parents so his interviewers
asking him for the kind of story that
suzanne tells you
what did your parents do what kind of
games did you play together how did you
feel
and and uh mayor shapiro answers look
it's just not the way it is now parents
spending a lot of time with their
children
that's not that was not the case then
with me or with anyone
parents keep kept to themselves and
children grew up with whatever they
could get for themselves
so that is to say not all witnesses in
this
english american ecology endorse a
nuclear panel
a nuclear family paradigm but most
respond to it in some fashion even if
it's as a direct counterpoint
when piecing together their stories so
this is probably
the the kind of
rhetorical conditions to use carolyn's
phrase that you're most familiar with
and now i want to talk about
um the one that i brought in to this
book that hadn't been researched at all
the one that i in fact started with i
conducted interviews
in yiddish in lithuania and i want to
focus on
the uh testimony of dober rosenberg who
was interviewed by the show
foundation institute in kovana lithuania
kaunas in 1996.
she was born in 1928
whereas testimonies from this
english-speaking american corpus are
rich with resources for discussing
emotional exchanges between parents and
children
yiddish lithuanian testimonies display
abundance
of a different sort they speak a great
deal about a broad
family community matrix alongside many
different categories of blood relations
mishpoche
families all of which are synonyms for
family
witnesses devote much attention to
people with a much
hazier kind of closeness friends
acquaintances
townspeople or those they simply call
under ours
as shorthand for this whole semantic
cluster i use the term
the egg in it the aegin in one's own
this adjective crucially can be used
alone functioning as a noun or be paired
with a whole variety of reference
that means that one's own what a
universe
is tellingly left open it can refer to
family
friends townspeople schoolmates
co-workers and others with some
significant shared experience
doba rosenberg born in your break in
1928
interviewed by the showa foundation she
introduces herself on camera by
declaring
a yoburiker i myself am a your breaker
in the present tense so even
in 1996
she's discusses herself she presents
herself as a part of this local matrix
in a place that for her
doesn't really exist anymore in the
present tense this is still
the best way to say who she is on camera
um dopa narrates the first days of war
as they affected the eurobiker
collectively
she reports on the fate of a broadcast
of characters such as my mother's
brother
uncle fivel my father's brother uncle
max
doba spreads her narrative focus among
many your brother care
but does take special care when speaking
about her parents
she's brought to tears when she recounts
her father shouting
watch out for yourselves look out for
one another as he was caught and led
away from their house in an early
roundup of the town's jewish men
however following her father's capture
surprisingly
doba's narrative quickly progresses
she tells us that she and her mother
found shelter in the house of someone
she describes as
quote the neighbor my mother's cousin's
husband abba wales
so rather than delving into her
emotional reaction to the loss of her
father
she shifts her social emphasis onto this
other relationship
she performs a similar shift immediately
after recalling
the capture of her mother doba was
knocked unconscious when her
when um local lithuanian
collaborators took away her mother and
she says when i woke up i was already at
the vises
with at her house my mother's cousin
with her kids of course i screamed and
cried and they all
comforted me and what's especially
different for comparing
the testimony of susan h to dober
rosenberg you recall
that suzanne h she really
felt um almost nothing towards
her surrogate parents they were
unnatural they yelled at her
she she wet her bed when she was brought
into a new household
and doba actually treats this kind of
shift as natural
and she claims that it was in keeping
with the way that she was brought up
before the war
she says of course this mira melne
henya's daughter and my mother were
always like sisters we'd always been
like one family
her acceptance and justification of this
new family arrangement
stands in contrast to a wide variety of
reactions that i found among
american witnesses who address surrogate
parents with disappointment or humorous
discomfort
so um doba has essentially become a part
of this new family
in in yearbook and uh they
they take parent-like responsibility for
her and using a whole wide variety of
connections
all of which she she explicates on on
camera
actually in um nishowa foundation
archives they have a short informational
questionnaire which the interviewer is
supposed to fill out
and um there's a white blank space about
this big on one of the pages
asking for the people named in the in
the interview
and most of the time that suffices
that's the apparently since that's the
space that they were allotted
and in in doba's case the interviewer
actually had to add on two pages
in order to list all the names that doba
includes and i think that the naming the
inclusion of of so many
characters is significant that is it
expresses an expectation
that the listener is going to be able to
follow along this is relevant
information i can follow
doba's mother's cousin's brother and
fibers so first of all it says something
about who
her expected audience of memory is she's
accustomed to telling her story to
people
who know this matrix and it says
something about
her sense of self that it's spread among
this whole chorus
of people um that this is this is not um
this is not a diversion for her to go
into this long
chain of names this is actually part of
who she is
so through this long um chain of people
this cluster arrives in
the covena ghetto and upon their arrival
doba encounters a new version of her
aegonic collective and i'll
play you a bit of her testimony
at this point and pay attention pay
attention well
i'll i'll stop in the middle and tell
you what i want you to pay attention
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
something interesting about the kind of
socialities that don't interest
doba so the interviewer asked her what
happened to her her belongings
and she says i i you know i don't know
there was some some station there with
people so she's not interested in
whether her belongings went to the uden
rot
or to some community organization who
took it away so
um this is in distinction to israeli
testimonies i'm not going to discuss
that she's not
really interested in formal
associations of people formalized groups
that have names on them you know
political organizations there's not one
mention
she's not interested in youth groups
she's interested
specifically in this agenda this
informal
and flexible type of of um
of group of bonding and i'll just play a
little bit more for you and do note the
number of names that come up and also
the details that she shares about these
people their addresses and so forth okay
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
did
[Music]
so note how her memory
of her bodily life is also in concert
with her notion
of belonging she doesn't survive by
distinguishing herself or running away
from people or being strong she actually
depicts survival as a kind of
cuddling type of activity and she says
she details that she slept on the floor
with her grandmother and she goes on and
says
who shared a bed with whom so in a sense
um
also surviving is is about
melding in with people in this kind of
through these kinds of small motions
um her intonation even while she's
telling i realize that that it's
it's it's hard to watch too much of it
when you're not um
when you're not that familiar with it
precisely because there aren't really
these big climatic
moments in her testimony and there
aren't really what we consider
cathartic moments it's really a kind and
there's a kind of
continuous pulse to it and that too
in a way echoes and amplifies
her way of presenting belonging as as
aegon as something with these
um movements and replacements and
adjustments rather than a really sharp
overturning and flipping around the
world like we saw with
suzanne h this does not mean
that doba's testimony is more upbeat or
that this is a resilience
narrative as in uh in opposition to a
trauma narrative
um doba because doba keeps repopulating
the agony as the testimony goes on
she actually has to lose more people too
and this is
palpable this is in the testimony for
instance
while she was in in the still in the
coconut ghetto she bonds with a young
cousin's cousin cousin um aviva
and when aviva was taken away she says
i didn't want to go because this aviva
was to me like uh
how do you say it i loved her very much
and she loved me
this moment is actually one of the few
in the testimony when doba speaks
explicitly of
love throughout the whole testimony so
in her
emotional repertoire um these are not
instrumental relationships this is love
um this aegonic belonging practice
it's really a practice it's not a set
group of people so even with these
pronounced breaks
in her circle of belonging the overall
framework of aegon adjusts and continues
to organize her social interactions
one way in which doba performs this
conceptual adjustment this
stretching of the aegina network is by
loosening
her geographic criteria of
identification
while she was in kovna dobba considered
herself a yearbook
but once she is taken away to an
estonian work camp erida
doba begins to speak of herself as a
covenant and everyone who is in covenant
is now part of her circle
then when she's taken away to stutter
about a year later
also the prisoners from eredar are
included into her circle
and um there in kovna excuse me in
stutthof
she bonds together with this particular
group of women
floyd shapiro mrs shapiro mrs kardash
carne
shivsky and malcolm gimpel and these
become
co-protagonists of her story and she
actually tells
great detail what happens to each one of
them
sharing the narrative stage with these
other
individuals the agent is not just a
system of inclusion it's also a system
of
exclusion dobas specifies for example
that prisoners
who arrived at stutto from romania were
also
jewish but she quite she qualifies
quickly
they stayed separately they weren't
egging it and she feels this also on her
return she returns to lithuania
she depicts the country as a desolate
place a place of ruin
in which jewish survivors regroup
according to some
new application of old ideas she
recounts her arrival at this train
station
we arrived in vilna the vilner came and
started to ask if maybe some of their
agony were there
they gave us a place to sleep we stayed
there a few days and then we moved on
so doba seems to understand share a kind
of
normative language with these vilner to
understand that they're looking for
their agent and she's not one of them
she moves on progressively going back to
her original site
of origin and goes back to your brick
and there she finds none other than abba
vilas
the mother's cousin's husband who took
her in
at the very beginning of the war and the
way that she describes this encounter is
truly
as a type of homecoming um
she says abba spotted me like his agent
like his own child he took me in right
away
and he kept me like his agent child like
his own child
so abba and doba recounts it to
a household and she lives there up until
her wedding in 1946
doba hastens to mention that the man she
chooses to marry is quote also
a your burdicker again a title that
remains
relevant in the present tense in 1996
when she's talking
and she also identifies the families
that her children married into by citing
microgeographic origin
she tells for example my daughter in law
is from zara sai
which is an eastern lithuanian town
thus in her post-war and current state
of being dobo depicts herself
embedded in the kind of group in which
she began her story
it is not that doba's family story is
one of resilience again and the
testimonies from the english american
corpus focused
on laws doba also depicts post-war life
is
incomplete most members of her original
group have been destroyed
but the criteria that enable people to
connect
survive the holocaust
so why is this it's a surprising way of
narrating the holocaust to to
cl to claim even implicitly this type of
continuity um i think that in this group
of testimonies studied here witnesses
formed their narrative habits in both
the language and physical environments
of pre-war life
and i do believe that physical landscape
is very important in shaping memory it's
not only about words and what people
read in the newspaper and hear their
friends say it's also
the sights that they see out their
window and i think that this
doubling of lingual and and physical
continuity encourages a type of semantic
continuity in their memory
to amplify and focus on these types of
conceptual
through lines from the pre-war to the
post-war period
so and again i i want to point out that
there are witnesses from the same
environment who ridicule the aegine
as a platform of memory i interviewed
one woman in kofna
named uh riva s and she
i i learned to talk about the aegon i i
conducted 47
interviews in in yin-ish and lithuania
and they taught me to talk like doba
you know everybody adjusts so i was
asking what was your cousin's name so
far then she
had no patience for that whatsoever she
wanted to discuss and i quote
public life you know different jewish
organizations on the street
and by that she meant the communist
underground
she told me nothing about cousins she
openly disliked the children from her
covenant neighborhood who joined the
zionist parties
that is to say the subtly flexion
flexible notion of kinship
that i've been calling the aegine is not
a requirement of testimony in this
yiddish speaking lithuanian cluster but
one that witnesses have to address in
some manner even if in disdain
so um i i
am going to conclude my talk here in two
different ways it's going to sound kind
of like a dora's song that has you know
this ending and then they have that
ending
one of the one of my conclusions is is a
major claim of my book so i really
wanted to get it out there and
and have you hear it and then another um
of my conclusions
relates to the contribution that yale
scholars made specifically one yale
scholar made in
in informing my research so
what does it matter what i've pointed
out here you know okay so
those one testimonies about continuity
and one
you know has a specific point of break
and i think that it's more than just uh
it's more it's it says something about
the event itself and it relates this
different distinction relates
to an ongoing question that's been
kicked around in holocaust studies
for quite a while and it is is the
hollow was the holocaust a catastrophe
in the strict sense of the word as you
all know
since you're smart and you're yale um
so i i don't need to tell you the
catastrophe doesn't just mean a mass
amount of human carnage and
suffering catastrophe means this is from
oxford english dictionary
an event that produces the subversion of
the order of things
a catastrophe is a dark cultural
revolution
in a sense and um
that claim i
think you know people go back and forth
about it on an empirical level
is that they can prove you know some
certain
amount of cultural change that would
determine which would answer this
question sufficiently and i actually
think that this question is open and
that um
the the postwar setting of memory
completes the meaning
of the event and gives shape to whether
or not this is a catastrophe or not
so in susan's testimony and others like
hers
there is a distinct moment as recalled
it comes from her body
in which things broke and they had to be
rebuilt in a new way so it's catastrophe
on the most
intimate bodily personal uh level for
her and then it expands out into her
worldview she changed her language
she changed her place of of belonging
she changed the way that she's jewish
and i don't think that catastrophe is
um an accurate way to describe the way
that doba and
some others in her ecology narrate the
holocaust
that is they describe no less of
suffering
and carnage and loss and injustice but
they do so through a very surprising
lens
of conceptual and cultural continuity
so it's mass violence
massive injustice mass wrong but not
catastrophe in the sense of a dark
cultural revolution
or a subversion of the order of things i
know that that's a surprising
claim to make but i think that that's
something that we should respect
comes from outside of our centers of of
cultural
um norms and and what we're most
familiar with
and this is a part of of of this era of
translation
when we leave our our comfort zones
we have to be ready to accept new things
and i think that that's one of the most
beautiful achievements
of holocaust testimonial projects
of the 20th century was that um they you
know
different organizations also the fortune
of organization
went abroad and they made these
surprising discoveries they didn't just
record more and more of the same they
they have
these archives with surprising
inflections of
of how to see the holocaust so my second
conclusion as i promised you the doris
style ending comes from a response
that the late jeffrey hartman offered
when hearing my work
describing what i was then writing my
dissertation on
i think if our encounter was back in
2010
i told him that i wanted to explore the
differences between clusters of
testimony
that relate to language and place and i
unfolded my basic thesis to him as i
have in this
lecture today about different genres of
testimony
different moral and rhetorical emphases
that arose in these
different ecologies i was studying and
hartmann's
response was quite surprising
he listened to my thoughts on
testimonial difference
and then corrected me he said
no it is not difference that you are
actually
studying it's something that is the
opposite of difference
and um of course he was right
scholars have always known that each
individual holocaust testimony which is
accompanied by a unique individual
interviewer will produce something
different what the comparison shows
is actually how there are communities of
truth telling
how clusters of people who are bonded
together through language and place
build a common language of memory
um and they build a shared method of
going into this
adventure of testimony together
and contrary to some i do not see this
shared language of testimony within each
ecology
as in any way a downside or a sign of
inauthenticity
quite the opposite without some common
frameworks
without those shared rhetorical and
thematic moves
survivors would have never had the
social support
for testifying in the first place so if
we think
of shoshana feldman and dory lab's work
on testimony as an i
thou relationship there's no way that
people could say i
and thou without some sense of community
in words and
in norms and and it's almost like some
of these um
shared aspects these these shared
topoint the testimony are like rituals
of inclusion and ways of signaling to
one another
that they have um a somewhat safe space
of memory together
so this is um not about difference this
is about
actually um really surprising ways in
which
people choose to to share
their ways of remembering so thank you
very much
[Applause]
go back to the general things it's so
nice
so oh
thank you sorry
deborah did you want to come up to the
podium okay
testing
very good
so i um before we get to the before we
get to the
question and answer sec part of
our time together i
i have the privilege of
drilling down on some of the things that
hannah has been
discussing and i should say straight
away
i was one i was an external reader
for her dissertation on which this
book is based and i thought wow
that's a brain two feet and then
the book was um accepted by the
city press or rather came to me as a
manuscript
and that was really a pleasure to see
how it had
changed from a dissertation to
becoming a net script for publication
and again
i thought wow that's a brain
on two feet i think that this
is just wonderful work and so
i want to use this time to learn more
about it
and to learn more what have thoughts
on her work so the first
issue that i would like to raise not
surprisingly
is gender as we saw the two
people on whom hannah focused her
lecture today both of them
are women she also mentioned
that there was a difference between the
way suzanne
h and meyer talked
about their families that she
susanna h talked about family
and relations and emotional history
while he did not so i just wonder
if you would be so kind as to talk to us
about the role of gender as you see it
in this work
okay i'm looking it up because i wanna i
wanna um
use so
um i think that you're right first of
all
over the years i was really resistant to
the suggestion
that came from you and looking at this
and um it's always a great it's a great
pleasure to say i was wrong
i don't know how many other people in
this room have gotten that privilege but
it's a really big one
and so there this could have been
a whole dissertation book could have
written been written just about gender
and gender
not in the sense of the biological
equipment of each individual
survivor but rather
gender associated means of memory you
know
some yes actually came up yesterday too
that you know yes are you
are you an agent are you strong or are
you
someone who focuses on his or
her suffering and victimhood and that's
that is gender you're right but it's not
just for women
and i think that there is something
feminine that's more
available to witnesses in
the uh english american ecology for
different reasons and i just want to
share with you one example of that
from a um a
a witness named jack arnell
who was a show of foundation witness and
i'll offer you
a quote because i do want you to know
there's actually stuff in the book that
i didn't
present today um i
want the audience to know that there so
so he's
he's this is in a different chapter this
is about the victim perpetrator
encounter
and he has jack arnell he's describing
the moment in which he was
he and his family and his community were
evicted from their homes and forced
into the vilna ghetto and this is an
opportunity to describe
the perpetrator and he uh elects
not to describe the perpetrator but
something else and he says quote there
were polish and lithuanians who would
jump on people and grab their bundles
sickly people the content sprawled out
it is a scene
that has made a very very big impression
on me
i just walk around with a big pain in my
heart
so the emphasis of that moment
for jack arnell is also on
the emotional stakes the
what the imprint that it's left on me
which is you know the very
it's a very freudian notion of the self
that he's built out of these imprints
and that's what he's interested in and
it is it is effeminate in a way and he's
okay with that i mean he's
he's he's going there and i think that
that
is um that type of of
of uh effeminate memory is maybe less
available in the other ecologies but
there are other things that are
that are more available so for example
so again if we're talking about
um you know um i'll leave it i'll leave
it at that but again
um you know there are all of these
different
axes of comparison that one could take
up
so gender is one of them language and
place is another
difference over time is another one that
we heard about last night and
my object in the in the book is not to
overpower
any other other axes of difference but
to propose this framework as an
important one
and and also the two intersect so gender
difference
in the israeli context is really
different different than gender
difference in the american context or in
the lithuanian context
in in the israeli context a really
important part of
surviving the holocaust is becoming
strong
making a nation of strength and that
part of that narrative is about serving
in the army
you know and and that's not available to
the same degree to the women who witness
so they have to come up with all of
these
different jerry-rigged narrative patches
to make up for the fact that they can't
participate in that part of the of the
narrative that they want to participate
in
so gender's there and it overlays with
these other differences
and but i i go back to my original
assertion that i was wrong and you were
right
we were both right so i want to
i would like you to to stay on that
subject of these
different axes and you are
and of course your focus is on language
and on space on geography
um i was alerted to this
question of language by the scholar
robert
nelson bob nelson who is a child
survivor of the holocaust went on to
become a political scientist
his professor emeritus at perdue and
has thought about and spoken about
how he is a slightly
different person when speaking his
native
polish as compared we're
speaking english even though his
language of
literacy and adulthood and love
and family and culture all of those
are english so i wonder if you
could um try to tease out the two
for us so for instance do you
can you speak about and maybe not um
people whose language remains the same
but geography changes
anyway i would just love you to tease
out the sure
so i i won't go into too much you know
of
this um these kinds of
individual comparisons and tracks
because then i'm you know
making a um an excel chart for you but i
do want to i want to say one
one thing so yes um you know language
languages
and again i i um i go back to the notion
of
the language the conceit of an ecology
and resources because i'm not talking
about limitations i don't think that
this is about limiting what you can say
quite the opposite i think that
this is hard enough to talk about that
we need resources so the resources
that come from language um help people
to say what they want to say rather than
limiting who they can be and
but you know if we think about um
michael notion of language
and that um that
every expression
is a story it's an intertext
that's been compressed into those words
every idiom that we use has memory
it has references so when we enter into
that intertext of one language we have a
different
set of memories we have a different set
of
of imagined audiences and so it stands
to reason that we would be
somewhat different people in different
languages regarding language and place
when i was doing my work in lithuania
i began the project by interviewing
people in lithuania
i worked with a sociolinguist named
dovid katz and he taught me something
very important he said that once
language has been transplanted
in the long term not you know for two
weeks or something it actually becomes a
slightly different language
so this is especially true of
yiddish and post-war america
they came here yiddish speakers came
here
met with a yiddish-speaking community
who had already
developed their dialect of yiddish and
they had better
pick up on it or they wouldn't be able
to speak um
isaac bashevis singer has a famous essay
about yiddish and post-war america in
which he
says you know
an ice cream and he basically shows how
much american english has been
incorporated into the yiddish idiom it's
almost the new it's a new dialect it's a
new language so
so um i think and they had a literature
they had a newspaper every it was very
developed and so
my finding was that those who moved
immediately after the war to the us
and for whatever reason chose to testify
in yiddish
years later from the us they were
speaking american yiddish it was a
different web of
intertext it was a different it was a
different it was something else than the
yiddish that stayed in lithuania
now that those who who emigrated much
later
like you know with the wave in the 70s
or the 90s i mean i
there's one um testimony in israel
that i in yiddish where he had just
moved to israel
like six months before he was
interviewed so there was really no
difference it's as if he was still there
he had he had transported the language
and the associations with him and hadn't
jumped into this new community and so
forth i know this is getting
intricate but um basically a
language is is also tied to to a place
to an oikos and oikos
is a house and its contents and so
once you move to a new house the the
language changes
okay